hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's pizza händchen und zwar
sind die auch wirklich sehr schnell
gemacht ich habe bereits einen hefeteig
vorbereitet und zwar ist mein pizzateig
den ich auch schon in einem video
vorgestellt habe und davon ob ich jetzt
die halbe menge gemacht und man hat es
gleich richtig leckere pizza könnte mit
einer verfüllung das heißt der murat
wird sie lieben und vor allem als
fingerfood sind die wirklich ideal war
kannte waren oder auch kalt essen und
deswegen eignet sie sich auch ganz
hervorragend für die em-saison sag ich
jetzt mal oder auf allgemein falls man
einfach mal fingerfood braucht den tag
habe ich wie gesagt vorbereitet der ist
auch schon aufgegangen
jetzt werde ich noch die füllung zu
bereiten für die füllung brauche ich für
tomatenmark jeweils einen teelöffel
oregano und basilikum getrocknet etwas
pfeffer eine knoblauchzehe youtube und
50 gramm parmesankäse ich weiß der murat
wenn der das noch sehen würde würde er
mich wahrscheinlich
na ja er wird jetzt fragen auch noch
alle tassen im schrank haben nämlich das
zurücknehmen
das muss man jetzt zuerst einmal schälen
und dann werde ich das so fein mixen
also normalerweise brachen wird es ja
immer nur an oder schneiden scheiben für
eine pizza zum beispiel heute werde ich
es fein mixen und falls ihr kein zurück
habt könnt ihr zum beispiel auch salami
nehmen oder auch die pizza hähnchen
natürlich auch vegetarisch machen
ich würde dann vielleicht nur noch
gespür den geschmack im netz eine
zwiebel mit rein geben oder einfach
einen anderen tollen geschmacksträger
da muss jetzt diese haut weg
und dann schneide ich einfach mal einmal
in der mitte durch und schneit grobe
stückchen
und diese schriftstücke werde jetzt mit
dem mixer zerkleinern
den parmesan reife ich jetzt dazu dafür
nehme ich jetzt nichts mehr sagt kurz
raus und nehme die feinen reibe und
falls ihr jetzt keine küchenmaschine
habt könnt ihr das alles natürlich auch
mit einem pürierstab zum beispiel machen
wobei man damit institute immer
aufpassen muss dass man das vielleicht
vorher in stückchen schneidet ansonsten
kannst etwas schwieriger werden oder ihr
hört halt einfach geht ja auch
jetzt kommt dass mixa wieder mit ein und
dann kommt auch tomatenmark mit der 2
die gewürze die knoblauchzehe wobei man
eigentlich schon genug knoblauch mit
drin hat und etwas pfeffer
bis der deckel wieder drauf und nochmal
gut durch mixa
so viel passte jetzt aus und ich glaube
ihm besser ist würde ich sagen es
wahrscheinlich nur als er noch klein war
ich frag einmal naja jedenfalls nehme
ich jetzt den hefeteig wenig vorbereitet
habe und gebe ihnen auch eine vermehrte
arbeitsfläche und habe hier eine
teilhabe dafür
und falls ich das jetzt hier so und so
viel arbeit wäre könnt ihr natürlich
auch einen fertigen hefeteig schon
nehmen dessen bereits ausgerollt ist
aber ich finds ein hefeteig geschickt
ist immer sehr schnell gemacht man kann
ihn auf jeden fall und gehen lassen und
ihr könnt ihn zum beispiel auch schon am
tag vorher zu bereiten und im
kühlschrank einfach gehen lassen
also ich find der hefeteig für pizza ist
immer ganz einfach
jetzt hole ich den zu einem großen recht
heraus
die platte hat ungefähr die maße 40 x 50
cm und die bestreite ich jetzt mit
dieser passte
rezepte füllung ist verstrichen und es
wird natürlich einfacher gehen wir
meines tomatenmark verstreicht und dann
dies zog gewürfelt drauf gibt oder auch
die salami aber so hat man einfach eine
einheitliche masse und ich würde jetzt
auch nicht etwas dünner machen mit
wasser oder mit fett zum beispiel denn
das zur katastrophe fed das ist später
im ofen wirklich ausreicht und somit
auch nicht komplett alles bedenken das
reicht so schon jetzt schneide ich hier
rechtecke draus und zwar möchte ich
jetzt nicht zu kleineren kinder könnten
selber bestimmen wie groß oder gekleidet
die haben möchte
ich werde die teigplatten jetzt erstmal
viertel genau erstmal durch die hälfte
dann nochmal halbieren und in diese
richtung schneide ich sie jetzt in
drittel letztlich jedes rechtecke
nochmal diagonal durch das dreieck
entstehen
jetzt nämlich ein dreieck und legt mit
der spitze von mir weg und schneidet ihr
unten die kurze seite ein sieht man das
bisschen auseinander und rollt dann auf
da kann ich das zu einem herrlichen
formen
die hand ins netz geformt und jetzt
welche mit eigelb bestreichen ich habe
jetzt hier ein eigelb da kommt ein
esslöffel wasser dazu dann verstehe ich
das miteinander und bestreicht an die
spitze halten damit
für mich kommt jetzt noch etwas frischer
parmesan obendrauf und dann könnt ihr
die hörnchen entweder im kalten backofen
backen und sie dann währenddessen
ausgehen lassen oder ihr deckt sie jetzt
noch mal ab und stellten denn im heißen
backofen
ich werde sie zu machen dass ich sie in
der kalten backofen stellen und sie dann
daten aufgehen ich stelle den ofen jetzt
auch 190 grad und da müssen die hörnchen
so für etwa zwölf bis 15 minuten backen
die pizza gebacken und ich wollte euch
jetzt mal hier den unterschied der zwei
bleche zeigen und zwar hatte ich diese
pizza dieses pizza blech im kalten
backofen und dieses habe ich ohne
aufzugehen aufgehen zu lassen in den
heißen backofen geschoben
das heißt ihr müsst ihr wirklich
entweder vorher aufgehen lassen oder
eben in den kalten backofen schieben
damit die hörnchen zurzeit haben
aufzugehen
wendet euch die hören sind die nicht
gegangen sind in den heißen backofen
kommen dann haben sie einfach nicht mehr
die zeit um auch zu gehen und bleiben
dann eben kleiner also sich jetzt nicht
schlimm aber ich wollte einfach mal kurz
zeigen demokratisches leider gar nicht
zum probieren
deswegen richtig dass jetzt hier
trotzdem mal auf dem teller an
und wie gesagt findet die warm oder kalt
essen schmeckt beides gut und würde ich
sagen probiere ich heute einfach mal
aber du musst mit der kamera darunter
darunter und ich weiß
okay bin ich fertig jetzt kann wieder
hoch also die hand sind wirklich von der
konsistenz und ich habs jetzt kalt
gegessen
manche einfach zu kalt gegessen sind
wirklich sehr gut und vor allem sehr
würzig ich meine gut danach habe
wahrscheinlich keine freunde mehr weil
wirklich knoblauch wurst und knoblauch
noch zusätzlich mit dabei ist aber das
ist ja gar nicht schlimm dass sich für
eine große gemeinschaft gedacht für eine
party zum beispiel und wenn es alle
zeiten und sticken auch gar nicht mehr
also falls jetzt lust habt dieses rezept
ein rezept nachzumachen geht auch salehs
- lok data stets noch mal für euch und
ich wünsche euch jetzt schon mal ganz
viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal kann ich weiter essen wenn
wir ausschaltet
ihr fragt mich darüber warum ich nichts
vor der kamera probieren dann schaut
euch mal kurz diesen clip an wirklich
lecker und alles in einem pot von
gängiger ausdruck warnt pott berichtet
kommt aus dem englischen wahrscheinlich
der schlimmste denn hier ganz viele
fragen wo kaufst du am liebsten fleisch
100 kannst du antworten jetzt
interessiert mich der antwort nicht mehr
vertrauen
beide einem metzger des vertrauens sehr
schön gut jetzt ich es weiter
wenn ihr das ganze video von technik und
mir zusammen sehen wollt dann geht
einfach auf den youtube kanal von saturn
deutschland bis gleich